الموقف كان مختلف فيما يتعلق بلبنان لاحقا
تم التقارب بين بوش واشتراك حول لبنان
ودور الرئيس الراحل الرفيق الحريري كيف
بدا هذا التقارب
لماذا حول رفيق الحريري تحديدا
بالنسبه لرئيس الشيراك لبنان كان ما يمثل
المختبر فيما يتعلق بالتطور في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط اي تعايش
مجموعات اجتماعيه ودينيه مختلفه لو نجح
حتى التجربه في لبنان فهذا يعني ان هذا
يمكن ان ينجح في اماكن اخرى ايضا اذا في
هذا الوضع كان هناك احتلال لبنان من قبل
القوات السوريه وبالتالي رئيس شيراك بحث
عن دعم الولايات المتحده في وقت كنا في
كانت علاقاتنا سيئه مع واشنطن بسبب حرب
العراق كما اشرت اليه قبل قليل اذا كنا
نحتاج لموقف مجتمع دولي موحد اذاعه مشروع
مشترك كنا نريد على نريد قرار من مجلس
الامن
لمطالبه من انسحاب القوات السوريه من
لبنان لمنحي لبنان متنفس لمواصله
والاستقرار وتجنب التدخل الاجنبي
تعلمين كيف
حدث ذلك فتم اغتيال رفيق الحريري وبعد ذلك
لم تنسحب القنصريه الا بعد عام من ذلك
وهذه هي كانت النتيجه السياسه التي انتهجت
في ذلك الوقت